- You went to your childhood home.
Is that kind of special for you?
Where you grew up?
- I try to go there often,
just because it's nostalgic
for me, and I've gone every year.
Well, there's me.
I grew up there; everything
started from there.
I actually got to knock on the door,
and someone was finally there,
because no one's ever there.
It was just this chill
dude and he was like,
"Yeah, come look around."
He was so unfazed that I was there.
He was like, "Yeah, apparently
you wrote on this wall."
"Also there's a crib in
the garage if you want it."
- [Kelly] What?
- I was like, "My crib?"
He was like, "Yeah."
I was like, "My crib is in your garage?"
He goes, "Yeah."
I was like, "Can I have it?"
He goes, "Sure!"
I'm like...
He has all this stuff, and
I had written in the closets
that I was in love with Cole Sprouse.
- [Kelly] I am older
than you; who is that?
(cheering)
- Cole Sprouse was on Suite
Life of Zack and Cody.
- Okay, I know that.
- I was obsessed with that show.
I thought that we were
gonna be together one day.
(laughter)
Then I guest starred on the
show, but I kissed his brother,
and I didn't get to kiss Cole.
- [Crowd] Awww...
- I always feel bad for y'all.
I hate acting.
I don't know how you
do, you don't know where
their mouths have been.
- It was my first kiss.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah.
- Your first kiss was with
a stranger and an actor?
- On camera. (laughing)
- That's fine.
Oh my god!
- It was one of the worst days of my life.
- You know what, mine wasn't
acting and it wasn't camera,
mine was horrible.
It was like he was searching
for something with his tongue.
- Oh god.
(crowd gasping)
- I was like, there's nothing
in there, it's just my mouth.
And then I literally went
and spit in his bathroom.
It was horrible.